proposers i watch a lot of TV
it's how I become so smart at knowing
stuff it's also why I'm so disgusted
with the mainly shitty media or MSM and
their constant attacks on our president
that's why I like to take the time to
highlight the brave media voices that
have the courage to tell our president
he's doing a great job it's time for mad
props tonight let's honor one of our
presidents maddest props Fox News host
and juggernaut of justice judge Jeanine
Pirro now I hesitate to admit to a
schoolboy crush but this valkyrie
crushes liberals like schoolboys Donald
J Trump is the president for the next
four years deal with it you're either
with us or against us you namby-pamby
pathetic losers take them out in cuffs
shame on you shame on all of you for not
showing that you love this country as
much as the President does oh that voice
it just kind of melts your face and
judge isn't just her first name it's
also her job you need to know more so
here to fill you in a citizen journalist
Laura Greg
hello Jordan or as a judge would say
objection sustained
Jordan ever since my husband stopped
getting out of bed because the feminists
ruined his self-esteem I've been
spending my Saturday nights with judge
Jeanine
it's like getting a shot of adrenaline
right in the tit yeah in a good way
right the best way better than exercise
since I started watching Jeanine I've
lost two sizes and three teas which is
how you know she's telling you this
straight to the bone truth yeah well if
she's a tenth as smart as she is angry
she is I'm sure she is
she's quite a force to be reckoned with
because she knows one rule that anyone
who's against Trump should shut up or go
to jail yeah and she's a real judge jjp
knows both sides of the law she's been a
DA and a judge but she's also not afraid
to drive 60 miles an hour over the speed
limit or consider illegally taping her
husband to prove he's having an affair
we've all been there but what I love
most about jjp is her interview style
when the judge gets a chance to sit down
with Trump she doesn't kowtow she asks
the tough questions mr. president your
approval rating is soaring and you know
we can talk about the economy and the
low unemployment and the stock market at
CPAC you're at 93 percent approval
rating to what do you attribute these
incredible advances well I think that
I've had a lot of good ideas that I have
a lot of energy I get things done oh man
she doesn't give him he holds his feet
to the fire knowing full well he might
retaliate by doing things like inviting
her to his inauguration inviting her to
Trump Tower inviting her to the Oval
Office inviting her to rub up against
his third favorite son
even using the president's Twitter
account to repeatedly promote her show
like it was a Chinese steel Terrace the
Trump and the judge are like well tad
peas in a pie and their united by a
lofty goal to make America Clinton in
front of a firing squad right yes of
course Jinyu knows Hillary is an avid
viewer of her show because a lot of the
time she talks directly to her
you're a loser Hillary face it face it
and get back in the woods you want to
criticize Donald Trump unlike you and
Bill Donald Trump can't be bought he's
not like your philandering husband just
get back into the woods it's funny
because remember how Hillary would
sub-types hike in the woods and if you
like jokes about Hillary hiking you'll
be happy to hear the judge Jeanine shot
an entire field report looking for
Hillary in the woods of Chappaqua oh man
is it funny is it funny
is the Pope communist yes
but this it's funny I'm looking for
Hilary I can't find her Hilary well
looking for you
does Illinois Clinton drop off her
pantsuits here for dry cleaning
have you seen Hillary Clinton Hillary I
think she's in the woods of it she's in
the woods come out come out maybe she's
still reading what happened because she
can't figure out what happened who says
women aren't funny most of the men I
know my favorite genre of comedy is
harassing small business owners and
yelling at the ghost of political
opponents in the woods
Janeane hasn't just passed the bar she's
setting the bar for the whole media and
that's why she's one of our med bras
yeah well she really is they get a
lingerie at the amazing judge fitting we
love you